Schon seit Generationen sammelt vorwiegend Buben vor grossen Fussballturnieren Panini-Bildli. Seit sechs Jahren gibt es zu diesen Klassikern auch eine Alternative, das Schutti-Heftli.
Fussball wird eigentlich heute immer fast nur mit Geld verdienen und Geld machen, gleichgesetzt dabei ist es so viel mehr und wir wollen ja ein kleines Zeichen setzen, dass es auch um Leidenschaft geht bei Fussball.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch, heute in einer internationalen Ausgabe. Mein Name ist Max Sackop-Ost, ich bin der Genetzer bei Twitter und freue mich sehr, dass ihr alle zuhört, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, denn wir haben ein ganz, ganz feines Thema heute. Vielleicht habt ihr es im Vorspann schon erahnen können, vielleicht etwas überraschend, der Schweizer-Dütsche-Einschlag in diesem Intro. Wir reden heute über das Schutti-Heftli. Was genau das sein soll? Das werde ich euch jetzt dann gleich erklären, zusammen mit meinen Gästen, die heute mal die Ehre haben, sich selbst vorzustellen. Und beginnen darf gerne der Silvan Glanzmann. Silvan, was müssen wir über dich wissen? Hallo und willkommen im Rasenfunk.
Ja, genau, also eben. Bis jetzt heisst es noch Chuty Heftli auch in England. Mal schauen, wie das jetzt in England läuft überhaupt. Weil England ist schon auch ein Markt, also ein Markt, ein Land auch, das Illustrationen sehr gross schreibt. Das ist, glaube ich, da auch in Alltagszeitungen präsenter als in der Schweiz oder auch in Deutschland, glaube ich. Und Fußball natürlich sowieso. Also ich bin jetzt echt gespannt, wie die Kombination in England ankommt. Und ja, dann schauen wir dann, wie es weitergeht. Und wie viel man wachsen kann, ohne eben Panini zu werden, sage ich jetzt mal.
Kommerzialisiert.
Ja, dass es dann eben diese, ich sage jetzt mal, diese Seele ein bisschen verliert, die im Moment, glaube ich, noch da ist. Aber das ist so die Gratwanderung. Mal schauen.
Ja, wichtig wird, glaube ich, halt immer sein, dass so Leute wie Peter, auch wenn nicht gerade eine Aufnahme läuft, sagen, es macht mir Spass und es ist mir den Aufwand wert, weil ich auch dafür etwas zurückbekomme. Und wenn es Aufträge sind, ist es der bestmögliche Fall. Aber es kann ja auch einfach nur Freude an dem Projekt sein.
Ach ja, genau. Und das andere ist ja, sobald kleine, tolle Sachen in Anklang wachsen, werden größer. Aber das muss es ja nicht unsympathischer machen oder weniger liebenswert oder so.
Ja, wenn ich jetzt an ein Event zurückdenke, am Freitag, da war echt so eine gute Stimmung. Es waren so viele gute Leute, die von weit her gekommen sind. Alle haben zum ersten Mal ihre eigenen Sticker angeguckt und haben gegenseitig so gezeigt. Schau mal, welches hast du gemacht? Die einen konnten kein Wort Englisch oder Deutsch, die anderen kein Wort Russisch. Aber trotzdem ging das irgendwie alles… Ja, das ist dann auch so der Moment, wo ich denke, ja, das lohnt sich alles absolut, dieser ganze Aufwand, wenn ich so einen Abend erlebe. Und ja, da ist einfach wirklich viel, viel Herzblut und Freude dabei. Solange das so ist, machen wir das weiter.
Was sind das für ein Gefühl, Peter, wenn man die eigenen Kunstwerke als Sticker in den Händen hat?
Ja, super. Das ist halt schade, bei uns entfällt halt das Sammeln, weil wir bekommen natürlich, was auch mega toll ist, wir bekommen natürlich eine ganze Box und dann geht es nur noch ans Einkleben. Aber es ist mega toll. Ich habe jeweils ein paar in meiner Brieftasche, in meiner Portemonnaie und kann sie so ein bisschen verteilen. Du kannst sie natürlich nicht irgendwo in den öffentlichen Raum kleben, weil da ja noch dein Name drauf ist. Sie sind halt wirklich sehr klein, aber trotzdem, das Auge ist ja eine sehr effiziente Zoom-Maschine, da kann man da unglaublich nah ran und er kennt das eigentlich sehr gut.
Man kann sich auch super noch zweitverwerten. Ich habe mir immer meine Doppelten aufgehoben. Bei mir sind zum Beispiel alle Leitz-Ordner mit irgendwelchen Dokumenten. Jeder hat ein Bildliebe bekommen und das hat immer einen Sinn. Zum Beispiel der Rechnungsordner. Da ist ein ganz böse, grimmig dreimblickender Türke drauf, der wurde in einem recht aggressiven Illustrationsstil gebracht.
Die roten, die so knallrot sind.
Da kriegt man immer gleich die richtige Stimmung, wenn man zu diesem Rechnungsordner greifen muss.
Die sammeln sich dann natürlich auch in den Schubladen. In 20 Jahren kommen die wieder hervor.
Ein wirklich, wirklich schönes Projekt. Ich wünsche euch, dass das noch ganz viel Erfolg hat. Und dass es dir, Peter, ganz, ganz viele Aufträge bringt. Und du, Silvan, immer noch genügend Energie hast, das alles so durchzuziehen. Das ist eine wirklich schöne Sache. Und ich würde mir wünschen, dass viele Hörerinnen und Hörer vielleicht dieses Jahr auf das große Konkurrenzprodukt verzichten und sich das kleine Independent-Projekt holen. Und dann sagen können, ich kannte es schon, bevor es cool wurde. Weil das wird nämlich unmittelbar nach Veröffentlichung dieser Folge wahrscheinlich geschehen.
Ja, ich kann ja noch Bilder finden, das können wir noch aus so was zeigen oder was die Leute anschauen können.
Sehr gerne. Wenn du mir noch was schickst, dann packe ich das gerne auf die Seite. Und dann könnt ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, da mal drauf gucken und dann eben chuty.de besuchen oder chutyheft.ly, allein nur, weil die URL so schön ist. Und dann könnt ihr euch da einen Eindruck verschaffen. Und wie gesagt, es kostet viel, viel weniger. Es ist nicht gewinnorientiert. Man spendet noch etwas für den guten Zweck. Ich denke, das ist eine Menge an guten Gründen, warum man sich damit mal auseinandersetzen kann. Ich danke euch zwei. Ich weiss nicht, ob ihr noch irgendwas auf dem Herzen habt.
Äh, nee, da habe ich so viel geredet. Also gut, es gibt auch – wir haben auch eine Facebook-Seite. Da drauf ist im Moment ein Video. Also wir haben ein tolles Video gemacht, das mit den Schweizer Spielern zu tun hat. Und da ist das größte Chuty-Bildli der Welt rausgekommen. Das lohnt sich sicher auch, das anzuschauen. Oh ja, absolut. Chuty-Häftli auf Facebook.
Das kann man sich angucken, kann ich auch nur sehr empfehlen. Dann danke ich euch beiden sehr, sehr herzlich, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt. Vielen Dank. Und alles Gute auf beiden.
Danke auch, hat sehr Spaß gemacht.
Das freut mich. Und danke auch an alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die sich dieses 18. Tribüngengespräch angehört habt, dass so ein bisschen den Auftakt bittet zu den WM-Sendungen im Rasenfunk. Es wird täglich einen Kurzpass geben. Es wird zu allen deutschen Spielen eine Schlusskonferenz geben und weitere Tribünengespräche wie dieses hier. Das heißt, zur WM werdet ihr die volle Rasenfunk-Dröhnung bekommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und warum kann ich das tun? Weil ihr uns unterstützt. Vielen Dank dafür. Und bis zur nächsten Rasenfunk-Sendung. Ich freue mich auf euch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.